hi I'm Dan as Carlos mentioned I lead
engineering at glean and we're going to
talk about data Ops today so when I use
that phrase data Ops usually the
immediate next question is what do you
mean what is data Ops it's a phrase that
is thrown a lot or thrown around a lot
more often these days and I think
different people have different
perspectives and what data apps actually
means so let me start out by giving my
pitch of what data Ops is and why you
should care about it
here's what we do right we take data
about our business we write pipelines
and build charts and dashboards to try
to understand what that data is telling
us
hopefully that data leads to Better
Business decisions and then those
decisions end up back in the data right
so that's that's business intelligence
in a nutshell it's what most of us are
doing at a high level I've been in this
industry for a while and usually it's
quite a bit more complicated it's
probably not controversial to say
there's a lot of different stakeholders
at the end of that of that cycle they
all have really different needs from the
data they also have different levels of
familiarity with using data and using
tooling around it
we have engineering teams that are
writing pipelines moving data around
trying to understand what all these
Downstream people need
and then of course we have lots of
different kinds of data practitioners
data analysts data scientists machine
learning Engineers quality teams that
are all trying to model this data figure
out what it's trying to tell us and
empower the rest of our stakeholders
a lot of feedback loops between these
groups right we have the data people
talking about the stakeholders to
understand their needs we have
stakeholders teaching data people about
the business we have bugs getting sent
from stakeholders all the way back to
engineers
and then finally we have a lot of tools
and in particular for this talk I'm
focusing on the bi tool which varies
depending on your business but usually
you're putting it in between the data
and all those stakeholders and usually
the objective of that tool is to scale
the data team we want to help those end
users use data on their own answer
questions on their own without having
all-day to send questions to data people
to help them figure it out
so that's where we want the bi tool to
be successful
and I think a really key part of that is
establishing trust right if the end
users don't trust the data that they're
seeing in that tool
they very very quickly are going to stop
using it and then all this work that
we've put into making the model work
correctly is kind of going to waste so
trust is like the currency of the data
team and it's really critical to make
sure that trust level stays High
and my experience there's a lot of
there's a whole class of questions that
those stakeholders are often asking that
get in the way of that trust and they're
kind of questions that I think shouldn't
really exist anymore it shouldn't happen
in 2023 and I actually heard these kinds
of questions come up in like four or
five different talks over the last few
days so I know it's really top of mind
they're very operational in nature it's
questions like why does my chart
suddenly look different or when we push
this new data model well my bi tool that
I'm depending on still work or I I'm
looking at this table and it kind of
looks broken it doesn't align with my
intuition but I'm not quite sure why
it's all about change management and and
I think despite all of these tools we've
been throwing at the problem bi is often
a really fragile part of the stack
you're always kind of worried whether
it's working correctly
and this to me is is what data Ops is
really all about it's about looking for
principles and techniques and patterns
that we can use at the top of the stack
and the visualizations to make it feel a
lot less fragile and in particular using
code to accomplish that so borrowing
principles from engineering and other
disciplines to start using code and
automation to make bi feel less fragile
so in the talk I'm going to talk a bit
about why this has been hard like why
hasn't data Ops really exploded I think
compared to other kinds of engineering
Ops things
I'll give a pitch for how I think we can
make progress how data Ops can start to
fix those problems
and then walk through a few practical
strategies that you could use in your
own company to start going from zero to
one in your your data Ops Journey
so a bit about myself first so I started
off my career I'm a software engineer
I worked on Google analytics so we were
helping advertisers understand their
data
and from there I moved on to at the time
a small company called Flatiron health
and our job at Flatiron Health was just
to to connect with oncology clinics so
doctors that were treating cancer
patients
we would ingest data from those clinics
about the patients try to extract out
useful information clean it up model it
and then provide it back to clinicians
and researchers and scientists so they
could use that data to understand how is
cancer being treated in the real world
which treatments are working better than
others
so even though this was a pretty
technical domain there were a lot of
non-tech details in there it really was
just a big business intelligence problem
and that's actually where this diagram
came from so we had a lot of different
stakeholders that knew a lot about the
business
they had really deep expertise in their
areas of ownership so medicine
Pharmaceuticals Manufacturing
and they also were very motivated to use
data they were very data literate
but they weren't particularly technical
they were not going to sit down all day
and write python or SQL to answer
questions so our job as the data team
was to to help them right to get data
into their hands and have them explore
it on their own and use it effectively
and it turned out this was like a really
hard problem putting aside all of the
challenges of cancer treatment just
moving data to a place where
non-technical people could use it was
really really hard and there was a lot
of things that went into making it hard
but in particular these these
operational problems were really hard
for us to solve these things were
constantly breaking and these clinicians
who had plenty of other important things
to deal with would lose trust in the
data really really quickly
so
a lot of the problems that that we
encountered at flat iron Health inspired
where I am today a company called glean
founded by my colleague Carlos who also
worked at Flatiron we're building a bi
tool that attempts to make this problem
better and in particular I'm focusing on
the operational parts of it today and
when I look back and think about why was
this so hard
there's a few gaps that that came to
mind that I felt like we were missing
and it feels like it's kind of missing
in a lot of these situations
first one is that it was really hard to
Version Control things
so when something would change and we
would get a question like hey why does
this dashboard look different it was
very hard to answer did somebody change
the dashboard did my team change it did
you change it did the data change you're
kind of on this mystery quest every time
a question came in it took a lot of time
there were also not really many tests
and especially not integration tests and
this meant we would push a change it
would have a bug in it a month later a
doctor would say hey this data point
just looks wrong I don't think it's
correct and they'd be right
and as an engineer like that's the last
thing I ever want to see happen right if
a user is bringing you a bug that's
really critical it's a strong signal
that there's a many missing
opportunities for testing and validation
in between the thing you built and
giving it to the user right so when
we're building an application there's so
many checks and balances we try to put
in to avoid that happening and it felt
like we were doing very little of that
when we were building charts and
dashboards
there wasn't much automation either and
this became a problem when there were
changes that spanned different layers of
the stack which is frankly what we were
doing like almost all the time where we
were changing a pipeline we were
changing a database and we were changing
a dashboard and that needed to be done
by a human clicking buttons and it was
really error-prone and often led to a
lot of mistakes
and finally overlaying all of this was a
really slow development cycle so when
there was a bug or when a user had a
great idea for a new data point to
expose there was a lot of picking up the
laptop and like tweaking the chart for
them and asking if it looked good and
then going back to my desk and coming
back a week later but they were busy
there was no easy way to send them a
draft there's no easy way to like
collaborate asynchronously on this stuff
which again meant that people sent us
feedback less often because it was
taking so much of their time
so
looking at these challenges kind of end
to end it reminds me of a really similar
problem that happened in a different
area of engineering about 10 years ago
or so so picture yourself in 2014
there's this new thing called the cloud
new-ish thing and there's this big
migration from on-premise infrastructure
to cloud-based infrastructure and in
those early days a lot of this was done
pointing and clicking in Cloud uis
setting stuff up and it felt very
fragile and actually a lot of the
problems that I just mentioned were
happening to these folks as well right
oh we don't know how to Version Control
the changes to our infrastructure we
don't know how to test this and we keep
pushing things that are breaking
suddenly you can change a lot more about
your infrastructure quickly introduces
the need for more tooling and more like
disciplined practices and I see a
cylinder thing happening in in data
where we have all these new tools but
fewer practices and patterns to make
sure that they stay safe
so the solution in the Ops World in
infrastructure was devops which is now
par for the course right back then was a
really pretty revolutionary idea which
was we're going to take this operational
thing managing Cloud infrastructure
and we're going to treat it just like
software development
we're going to have code that represents
what we want to do
check it into get we're going to use
pull requests and code reviews and
approvals we're going to write tests
we're going to write automation
and it turned out this was a really good
idea and it solved a lot of the
operational friction that often happens
when you're doing infrastructure work
and it wasn't just devops right so if
you look at the whole data stack
over time really the last five years or
so
there's suddenly been a lot of access
code getting applied to different layers
right
we have terraform and devops
ETL 10 years ago I used to be running
SQL scripts manually I'm going to
schedule out of calendar like
invitations remember to run the script
right but now we have tools like dagster
and before the airflow represented as
code I can test it I can serve it on a
schedule
and then after that we have DBT where
these data transformations used to be
spread across their different systems
now we have a data model we're checking
in we can deploy it to a staging
environment we can review it we can
preview it all these good practices that
we've inherited from other areas
and so I think bi is the missing link
here we haven't quite coalesced around
a standard way of managing this stuff as
code or at least with good engineering
practices to prevent this stuff from
breaking and and that's to me this is
like how how data Ops fits in
it's not a new idea right like code can
be good a lot of us know that I'm not
the first person to say this so why
hasn't it happened why is data Ops not
as ubiquitous as devops in terms of
practitioners there's no hiring a data
Ops engineer right even though there's
plenty of that for devops
I think there's a few reasons I think
that bi is kind of uniquely different
than most other areas of engineering
that have made data Ops a harder thing
to kind of make it stick
so I'll list out a few challenges so
first and I think probably the most
important one is that bi has a really
wide range of use cases there are times
when you want a really governed set of
metrics that never break you have
dashboards that are critical for your
business executives are making million
dollar decisions
it's really critical that they're always
correct and version controlled and
approved
but on the other hand
often the most powerful part of data is
the more exploratory mode where you are
having hypotheses collaborating in real
time digging through the data coming up
with new charts and that kind of
improvisational exploration is really
critical to data being well and it
doesn't really suit itself to the kind
of you know light friction you apply to
something like writing something in code
or doing a code review
and so I think whatever solution we come
up with for data Ops it has to bridge
those two worlds really naturally you
have to be able to treat some things as
important for code and something's not
and have that be a really seamless
switch back and forth
beyond that bi is inherently visual much
much more so than other other kinds of
engineering so in in devops that can
look at a terraform plan and I can see
that it's adding three ec2 hosts and a
new database and a new schema whatever
and I can be pretty confident I
understand what it's doing
but I can't look at a Json file or a
yaml file for a line chart and be
confident I know it's going to do I
really have to render that chart I have
to see it in the context of the data I
probably have to show it to somebody
else and get validation that it's
correct and I think that makes the whole
doing it as code kind of challenging
it's also much more interdisciplinary so
when I'm writing terraform code my
Reviewer is also an engineer they know
what the code how the code Works they've
done code reviews before
when I'm building a dashboard my user is
an executive or an operations person
right I the product is the data the user
is everyone else and they may not be
used to writing code they may not want
to write code that makes it challenging
to fit into the system
and then finally there's inherently a
really big number of dependencies so
your bi stack is at the very bottom of a
very very long chain of dependencies
going through DBT and Snowflake and
5tran and your application itself and 20
vendors that are piping you data and any
change in any of those systems could
potentially be impacting the correctness
of your bi stack
so that just makes it really hard right
and I think that's a lot of us spend our
time trying to manage all that chaos and
it's a bit harder to take a step back
and think about how to make it a bit
more of a process
but I think we can solve it like these
are this is kind of the challenges we're
looking to solve and so I'll walk
through a pitch of how we can start
thinking about dashboards as code to get
around those challenges so
here's a diagram of a bi Tool uh it's
pretty generalized so you have data on
the right side there you have your DBT
pipelines that usually live in code
somewhere
you have some modeling layer and there's
a lot of different ways you can do that
probably you've heard five different
options over the last two days right it
could be a model built into your bi tool
it could be a semantic layer it might
just be a SQL query but at some level
somebody is saying here's how you go
from my raw data to my Core Concepts and
the metrics I'm trying to measure
then you have your charts and your
tables and your graphs that visualize
the data
and you have your dashboards that pull
them together and are used by your
stakeholders right so
when you lay it out like this it starts
to look familiar it starts to look like
a DAC it's a dag just like DBT is a dag
and your database schemas are a dag and
by dag I mean it's a graph of things
that depend on each other that have
relationships that you can Define uh as
a graph right and once you do this we
can start borrowing the data structures
and techniques that we've used Elsewhere
for representing dags right so DBT uses
the file system we can do that as well
so
here's how clean the tool that I work on
represents this dag we have the data we
have the model we have the views the
dashboards and you can imagine to the
right there's your DBT and your database
and your application I've even seen a
few different diagrams like this and
other talks
so
let's treat them as files maybe let's
say each of the nodes in our bi tools
graph is a file we can reference other
files we've now overlayed some code onto
this thing
could work but remember our big
challenge here
not everything might need to be in code
the code might be getting in the way so
the graph that we're designing needs to
be hybrid it also supports some nodes
that live and git and are governed and
some nodes that live in the bi tool and
are not quite as governed right and this
is a solvable problem right we can maybe
have an ID system that is spanning all
these things and you can reference a
resource by its ID and then have a
separate mapping that tells you is this
ID in git somewhere or is it in the bi
tool cool
so that's the first challenge but then
we have the visual nature of it right I
can't look at this code and see if it's
correct so to me this challenge is about
the tooling it's about the IDE
I kind of think we need a better IDE for
developing bi so that you can switch
back and forth between code and visuals
quickly so here's what we think about it
in glean and let's see if I can get the
video working
there we go
so this is glean uh anytime you're
looking at a visualization you can pull
out a code editor and the code editor
will be showing you the deterministic
and fake that will generate the thing
you're looking at
and there's two-way binding between both
sides so as I edit the visualization I'm
breaking out I'm exploring I'm pivoting
I'm doing probably kind of complicated
filtering all of that is automatically
syncing to the code representation on
the right
vice versa if I edit the code I see
those updates live in the graph and I
have things like autocomplete and inline
documentation and so this is a learning
tool right you can use this to learn the
language of the bi tool and it's also an
accessibility tool so if I have an end
user who wants to propose a change they
can just make the change and that sinks
to the code automatically if I'm an
engineer and I have a template somewhere
that kind of have already written up I
can paste it in so even without touching
a file system we've started to to
tighten that feedback loop between the
code representation and the visual
so thank you like it
now I have to figure out how to get back
to the slide deck
there we go
uh cool so uh visual is good but code is
good as well right we're Engineers I
think one reason DBT has become so
popular is you can use your usual tool
chain right you can use vs code and
command line and everything you're used
to so uh we can copy this code to vs
code as well we can even have it live
alongside your DBT code and suddenly we
have one unified ecosystem to do bi
development alongside our data
development
and that opens up things like Chase
tracking we can have a git commit that
shows which of my resources are changing
and which are not and in glean we were
inspired a lot by terraform so for those
of you who haven't used terraform you
can Define changes and then run a plan
and terraform will tell you which of
your changes are yet to be deployed into
AWS or Google
so we've built a similar thing for for
glean you can preview your local file
system and you can see
here are the views that I'm adding here
are the things I'm updating here are the
things I'm deleting and here are the
things that are unchanged but remember
this list itself is useful but maybe not
so useful if I can't see it so this
comes along with a visual preview as
well and I think I have another video
next
yeah so I can review this my chief
marketing officer can't and so
jumping back to a video
here we go
uh for all these builds I can click a
link I can jump into the tool and then I
can get a visual preview not just of
what I'm changing but of my whole DAC so
everything that's been built out
including what's in code including what
random people have built on their own I
can see with that yellow border around
it here's what this will look like if I
were to make this change and this is a
permanent URL I can send it to my
stakeholder I could send it to the
person reviewing my change and we can
explore we can even change it right we
can say you know what this is not quite
right I want to change the visual
presentation of this chart and you can
do that right at the tool
back to the slide deck there we go
and then when it's looking good we can
run a deploy which is just like our
terraform works we can see all right I
approved this change I want to
deterministically apply this to my org
and now everyone using glean can see the
things that have been changed
now we have an opportunity to write some
tests right so once this is all done
through a CLI and I think that's also a
pretty important part because the CLI
can be automated and it can be composed
so you can take a CLI you can put it in
a GitHub action you could put it in the
continuous integration system and you
can hook other stuff into it so testing
remember we have all these dependencies
right we would like to do some things in
an automatic way to prevent broken stuff
from happening because of dependencies
and now we have an opportunity to do
that so when we try to preview some
changes that I'm making
the bi tool green can do a bunch of
checks we can see hey are the tables
that you're trying to read from lining
up with how you've configured the graphs
and you can kind of Imagine This Guy's
the limit for the kind of logic you can
put into these tests maybe you want to
test that the graph is always going up
or that there is exactly five data
points in this chart because if there's
more or fewer we're doing the
calculation wrong right so it's all
about coming up with Primitives
foundational building blocks so you can
then tie together and start adding
automation to
I think this becomes especially powerful
when you start dealing with changes that
span layers so suppose that you're
changing a DBT schema there's a new
column or a rename column and to make
this work well you also have to change
your bi tool this is where I think most
of us get into trouble because it's that
manual coordination across different
layers of the stack
uh but with these kinds of parameters we
can start building up patterns to test
these well so for instance we can point
I can run DBT at a target of a Dev
schema I can generate a preview of my
whole bi stack reading from that Dev
schema I can review it I can send that
to a stakeholder I can make sure the
data looks right so this is helping us
validate the data as well
I can now review both of those chains
together or they can send a pull request
that's saying hey I'm changing this
column I'm also changing this in my bi
tool they're in the same repo I can make
sure they all line up
and when it looks good we can also
deploy them together this is what we do
internally with our own data inside of
glean we run DBT on airflow and then we
immediately deploy our own glean assets
to glean and that way we're guaranteeing
that if something's not right we'll get
notified but otherwise the bi layer and
the data layer are always in sync and I
think this is kind of the thing we
should be striving for is patterns to
help those transition points between
layers stay in sync
so
last section here I'll walk through some
some ways you can start putting these
strategies into practice and a lot of it
depends I think on your use case
do you have a lot of governed metrics
that are really critical not to break
but a lot of stakeholders that are very
motivated to explore on their own
maybe you have really critical
dashboards that need to be versioned in
a really granular way because they're
super important
how do you want your engineers and your
stakeholders to collaborate sometimes
you want them sitting side by side
talking literally every day sometimes
you want to put in layers in between it
all depends on the information flow in
your business and what you want to put
in place
and deployment schedule is also a good
question so are you building things that
are changing every day every week every
month every quarter and how should that
impact how your automation works these
are these are very similar questions to
what we ask about application
deployments and data deployments right
so it's all about taking those same
operational best practices and thinking
about it even when you're building out a
charter dashboard but I'll walk you
through a few examples
this one is probably the one we see most
commonly inside of glean so you Version
Control your model which could be your
SQL could be the metric calculations and
you leave the rest of your visual Parts
on versioned or at least not check them
to get
and this gets you the advantage of
syncing together your data stuff and
your bi stuff so it doesn't break but it
leaves a lot of flexibility for your end
users to explore on their own and this I
think is especially useful on these
interdisciplinary organizations where
you have people that want to use data
and don't need a lot of help to do it it
does the kind of require that you have a
pretty mature model so if you have a
data model that is pretty easy to come
up with just nonsensical data or data
that's wrong this gets a bit dangerous
because those users can kind of go off
track so works best when you're you have
a mature model you're pretty confident
that it you the things you can do with
it are accurate for the business now you
want to let everybody else have a lot of
freedom
so that's one approach
you could also think in terms of
vertical slices so maybe there's a path
from your database through your
pipelines through your charts through
your dashboards that whole path is a
critical path and the number coming out
of the end is you know controlling a big
investor decision and it should never
change without your approval
but there's plenty of side quests that
come off of it that are okay right so
this is another way of thinking about it
you check in to get all the parts of
that critical path which helps you
control it
of course there's now a little bit more
friction to updating that end result
could be good if it's a really critical
thing it could be not so good depends a
bit on what you want to do
and the last one I'll leave you with is
doesn't really exist yet we do it a bit
in glean but I think there's a lot more
to go
again inspired by devops so in the early
days of devops we were working at a very
low level of abstraction but today if I
want to bring up a new
stack of ec2 servers or a database in
AWS I can import a module that's been
written by somebody much smarter than me
with a lot of best practices and I can
focus on how am I going to customize
this best practice thing and deploy it
to my organization
I think that the bi is just ripe for
this pattern to evolve all of us in this
room
are doing a lot of duplicate work we're
doing very similar things if you're a
SAS business we have similar metrics we
have similar dashboards we have similar
Pipelines
so why can't I import retention curve
template plug it into my data and have
it build a bunch of good charts and
dashboards to start with right there's
still going to be plenty of
customization but I think this is going
to happen because once we can do it it
saves us just so much time
to get there though we do need those
building blocks we need code
representations of the core parts of
this we need automation to plug it in
once we make it work well we can start
building this higher level abstractions
and really start sharing best practices
programmatically instead of you know
spending a lot of time talking
but it's still early days a lot to
invent devops is par for the course but
data Ops still don't quite agree on
always what it means I'm very excited
for this to start moving up the curve
because there's just so much more you
can do when you have code that you can
operate on right in this space
so summarize
fragile bi at least a lack of trust
which is the core currency of the data
team
the idea of data Ops is to improve that
trust by making things feel less fragile
borrowing engineering principles from
other areas to do it
but it's really hard and it's been hard
for a while and to do it well we need to
figure out ways to bridge the gap
between the UI part of bi and the code
part of bi between the engineers and the
data scientists and the stakeholders
come up with tools that they all love
and work with together and if we can
unlock that I think it's going to be
very powerful
that's it so yeah um quick plug for
glean uh I have these little cards go
somewhere you can get a free project and
glean and you can build a dashboard with
code we have some T-shirts I think to
hand out
um we'd love to chat about any of this
we think about this a lot uh and yeah
thanks a lot
[Music]